but speaking of guns let's talk about
some uh some cultural stuff uh I want to
talk about Alec Baldwin we got some
interesting news in the Alec Baldwin
front from deadline Alec Baldwin today
deleted his Twitter account and so did
Hilaria Baldwin Days After Shock ABC
interview and I will tell you my
thoughts I think he deleted his account
because his lawyers were like you dumb
mother effer
everything you said incriminated you in
killing this woman and I am uh uh I
wouldn't say I'm more convinced than
ever that he's a that he's he
intentionally committed murder I would
say that interview that Alec Baldwin did
with George Stephanopoulos was
incredibly incriminating and it sounds
to me like the probability that he did
intentionally murder this woman went up
a decent amount and I would put it at
like I don't know if I were to think
like what percentage of me thinks he
intentionally killed this woman it's
like 26 27 and then like 20 says it was
an accident or whatever but this whole
interview
it says to me this guy he did it
something's wrong there it's beyond
wrong man yeah I mean have you been
following the story I have I have no
absolutely and I I was surprised that he
actually gave an interview because if
you're under any investigation the last
thing you want to do is have more words
that Canon will be used against you
that's why you're you have the right to
remain silent
um so I don't understand why he did this
interview I also found it funny that he
chose Stephanopoulos because uh Steffy
probably thinks he is getting these
these big hits and like he's he's got to
have some some cool feature but really
it's because they know he's just an easy
interview if you are in trouble and
you're on the left go to Steffi
Stephanopoulos and and you will get a
cakewalk but even with the Cakewalk I
mean imagine if he went to a real
journalist imagine if he sat down with
someone who actually asked him oh I
watched roasted this guy so he went to
George Stephanopoulos for a cakewalk and
even in that Kate walk he said a lot of
stuff like the fact that he did or did
not pull us pull the trigger even well a
lot of people are saying that this is
rude to the fam family that's still in
mourning that he's making this kind of
big media spectacle around this and it's
also I you know if looking from the
outside it's also kind of psychotic to
try to Proclaim yourself as a victim
here which which he was in in my kind of
uh you know understanding of it was
trying to make himself out to be making
him the center of attention around this
when in reality you know this was a very
emotional issue that I don't think helps
anyone in this situation yeah well let's
let's talk about some of the facts and
some of the things he said and I'll I'll
just get straight to it one of the
things that really caught me was when he
made this argument Stephanopoulos asks
Alec Baldwin but I'll give you the quick
the quick elevator pictures to whatever
Alec bald was on the set of the movie
rust he pulled out a gun pulled it
pulled the hammer back fired it killed a
cinematographer and struck the director
there's a lot of other Nuance details
we'll get into a second but
Stephanopoulos said why didn't you check
the gun and Baldwin said you can't
when you're handed a weapon if I were to
open the the chamber or take the clip
out I know he said clip he meant
magazine he's like they would
immediately take it away from me because
it's been checked by someone else you
know he probably thought that was a
really good argument he probably was
thinking about doing the interview talk
to some people and they were like oh
tell them you can't check the gun
because then they would take it away
from you the idea being if they saw if
the armorer was checking the weapon
taking it apart putting it back together
checking the rounds hands it to Alec
Baldwin and then he opens it up and does
something to it the armor is now like yo
I just checked this what did you do give
that back to me I'm checking it again
but that's a really dumb thing to say
because I'll tell you this ah so Alec
Baldwin you recognize that the armor or
prop guy as he calls it hands you a
weapon you can't do anything because
that guy has to make sure it's checked
correct yes then why was it that when
you were handed the weapon by the A.D
who is not the prop person or the
armorer you did not find that suspect
enough to call for the prop guy and say
please check the weapon someone had
manipulated it if your argument is you
can't check it because they would take
it from you to check why didn't you call
for that when it was handled by someone
who wasn't the armorer that in my
opinion is incriminating additionally he
claimed when he was on the street and
the people the paparazzi were filming
him he was like she was my friend she
was my friend in this interview he was
asked what did you know about Helena
Hutchins nothing nothing until she came
on set she was your friend but you
didn't know her until she took this job
he didn't know she was so why was he
having dinner with her why was Alec
Baldwin having dinner with someone who
wasn't his friend he had just met that
could be that they're working on set and
they said let's go grab dinner and talk
about the movie but at the same time we
know that there was Labor concerns the
crew was complaining about safety
conditions and and pay and people are
walking off then we find out Baldwin's
having a a dinner with him he doesn't
know and he describes her in the
interview as intense not interested in
small talk just getting down to business
so I don't know
you would have to believe that Alec
Baldwin was handed this gun popped open
the the so these are single action
revolvers there's a little latch on the
right side you pop it open and then you
can see and you put the bullet in spin
the cylinder doesn't come out like you
see in like the video game so they flip
it out the single action so we'd have to
open the latch one by one load it while
spinning this you know spinning this uh
the cylinder and if he wanted to put a
bullet in it he'd have to put one in and
then close it very easy to do with in my
opinion I think it's a bit of a stretch
to assume that Alec Baldwin with one
hand was holding around reached over
because they had the gun on his side and
then popped it open pushed the ball in
and pulled it out then shot her
but I also think it's even it's it's
it's still more absurd to assume that
the gun had to be accidentally loaded
with live rounds to be to get given to a
guy who's not supposed to handle it to
be handed to Alec Baldwin who's not
supposed to use it in this set to then
Alec Baldwin claimed that Helena
Hutchins told him to point the gun at
her and pull the hammer back I'm like
I'm sorry if I'm if if that's the
official story and the alternative is
Alec Baldwin put a bullet a gun and shot
a woman I think the Alec Baldwin put a
bullet and shot a woman is much more
likely to be true but I'm not saying
it's definitive I don't know I'm just
saying it's more likely is he saying
that she said uh point the gun at me and
shoot at me because she's
cinematographer she's got a camera she
wants a POV director camera shot is what
she's she's looking to to shoot yes okay
that he was saying she kept saying you
know draw the gun Tarantino S Type angle
where you're literally looking right at
the camera or or at a slight angle and
so the camera's here and she's just to
the right of it and the gun is going
slightly off yeah but I'm sorry if his
argument is she was telling me over and
over again to draw the gun and point it
at me and then he says she told me to
pull the hammer back and then I let go
and I it just fired I didn't pull the
trigger that's not possible on a single
action revolver unless he was holding
the trigger depressed while pulling it
back which also seems like a strange
thing to do so all of these weird I said
this last month I was like all of these
coincidences had to have occurred for
Alec Baldwin to have accidentally shot
this woman sorry dude he was holding a
single action revolver you pull the
hammer back and goes click click I think
it may even go click click click you
can't just let it go it doesn't go
forward until you pull that trigger so
someone accidentally puts a ball in it
gives it to the wrong guy Alec Baldwin
knows that's not supposed to be the guy
who has it and he's supposed to get the
armor to come check it because it was
manipulated by somebody else and then
Helena Hutchins is like yes draw the
weapon and aim it at me now pull the
hammer back oh no I've been shot
directly through the chest hitting my
spine and killing her I'm sorry dude
Baldwin straight up killed that lady
going through her and hitting another
person uh behind her as well actor John
Schneider he was in The Dukes of Hazzard
came out and said that he doubts that
this gun went off by itself he also
called the whole interview bull-ish uh
family-friendly show you know what I'm
trying to say but he said that it was
designed to quote make us feel sorry for
Alec Baldwin and I think he made some
very interesting points surrounding this
it doesn't matter you see the guy did
the Youtube video
um I'm not sure which guy the guy from
uh what show John Schneider yeah he was
vote Duke yes yes yes yes yes
I I think this is the guy who took the
the single action he he took it apart
and he showed you exactly that was this
and he said that there was a propaganda
uh propaganda machine behind all of this
and as we know uh Alec Baldwin has has
been working with PR emergency companies
that have been implementing uh a lot of
the kind of fake news have been
implementing a lot of uh the the kind of
noise around this matter allegedly
according to a lot of sources surrounded
in this case so it wouldn't be so
surprising to me if a crisis manager
came to Alice Baldwin and said okay
we're going to sit you down we're going
to get rid of all this public pressure
we're gonna make sure you get back into
acting very soon and Alex said whatever
it takes
um and and I think this was a part of
the process that he taught would help
him but in in reality a lot of other
people are calling him out you know
what's really weird is that this woman
was an investigative journalist yeah
that's weird right and a lot of people
are there's there's investigating the
clintons well I know I know but there
are a lot of people pushing something
like that yeah and I don't see evidence
for that and I do think that's an
attempt to push people away from the
real story you got to be careful with
these really crazy conspiracies about
you know kids in basements at pizza
parlors because it is it is so absurd
and easily disproven but people believe
the trash they read on the internet what
happens is you have this very serious
story about Alec Baldwin who killed Owen
we don't know why she did work as we
have it here on a Wikipedia page she has
a degree in international journalism and
worked on documentary films as an
investigative journalist in Eastern
Europe
so all of a sudden you know she now
finds herself working as a
cinematographer from the PA for the past
few years
this woman was killed let's get to the
bottom of it but if people start pushing
these crazy theories about the the
secret undercover investigation she was
really pursuing then all of a sudden you
lose interest CNN comes out and says
it's a crackpot conspiracy it was on all
an accident and like that actor guy said
there's a propaganda machine trying to
make us feel sorry for alcohol when he
killed this woman yeah and I think I
think you raised a great point that if
you're Alec Baldwin's agent and his PR
staff the question is how do we get you
back to acting as fast as possible and
you look at the history of some
Hollywood unsavor reactors I mean heck
Roman polanski's gets standing ovations
at the Oscars yeah I mean because her
his PR machine was so good now granted
he's extradited in France that right he
can't come back uh and he won't come
back because he knows he'll get arrested
but Hollywood actors and actresses will
still applaud Roman polanskin yes he
raped a 15 year old girl but he's a
brilliant director and I'm sure if
you're Alec Baldwin's people you're like
what's that compared to Roman Polanski
or Harvey Weinstein or so many other
people in Hollywood
yeah wasn't there a famous actress that
made a speech about him saying we need
him back we should get him back it's
unfair what was her name was it I can't
remember was it Barbara or was it uh
Whoopi was it Meryl Streeper was someone
someone did a major major actress did
give a like we need him yes we need him
back was it the gap tooth one
um what's her name she's from the family
um the the whole all the families uh uh
what the heck's her name I just think
Alec Baldwin if you know look
I don't see how an accident it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's like
um final destination you know that movie
where the series of movies where the
people die in really weird ways like a
truck is driving on the street and then
some guy spells his coffee which like so
he throws it out the window and then it
bounces and then it hits a sign which
causes the sign to spin around and then
point in the wrong direction and then a
truck turns left but then slips on ice
and flips over and then the logs fly off
the truck bounce through the air hit a
car which makes the car fly off a bridge
and then hit a guy like that's what it
sounds like to me when when they explain
that this the scenario that happened
according to Alec Baldwin or there's the
really simple like more real-life angry
crew members Alec Baldwin was frustrated
tired angry has a temper and he said
screw this bang was he not supposed to
have a gun in that scene I heard that
the officials the official story uh from
the script supervisor and the
electrician was that he he was supposed
to have a gun but he wasn't supposed to
draw it or aim it and it wasn't supposed
to be handed to him by this this uh
assistant director so if he wasn't
supposed to draw or aim it why would
Helena Hutchins tell him to draw it and
point it at her well she's dead and she
can't tell us exactly why that was
happening the weird thing is and I'm
sure everyone's afraid to go public
because this is an ongoing investigation
with the exception of I've worked on a
lot of Hollywood scenes it was one of my
earlier little things long long time ago
there are no scenes that there are just
three or four people porn shoots have
staffs of 15 people right A lot of
people saw this happen the fact that
none of them have come come out publicly
and said what happened they're probably
all afraid they probably all have this
is this is definitely recorded on film
there's a lot of people who witness this
they're waiting for the investigation to
go I'll tell you that's right and I will
say one last thing if you don't mind
I've worked on movies with with uh
oscar-winning actors and oscar-winning
cinematographers oscar-winning actors
don't have dinner with cinematographers
like the stat didn't work with the staff
unless something is wrong an a-lister
meeting with a a new cinematographer he
just said it must have to do with the
crew something is wrong or like they
were like Alec you gotta take her out to
dinner because like she's gotta win her
over or she's only one putting up with
your BS so you and he was like fine I'll
do it but I've been on movie sets where
this they don't that stuff they don't
yeah they were pissed off because of the
budgeting they said that he was
undercutting everyone and not properly
funding the production of this movie and
they were saying this is this is
absolutely absurd so that could have
been you know the arguments that
happened there uh and again we don't
know we're not you know we can only
speculate from here you know the whole
where Alec was saying if I had taken the
gun apart to check they would have taken
it away from me thing is such a pansy
like that's what he would have done to
someone as the producer if he saw
someone checking inspecting their weapon
he would have taken out of their hands
and fired the guy because he's he's
lying because he doesn't have he's
impatient he doesn't have patience I see
what you're saying but he's just lying
that's also possible like George Clooney
was like I always check yeah because you
get in trouble if Alec Baldwin is like I
I didn't check because they told me I
wasn't supposed to it's like well you
realize that's still involuntary
manslaughter right like so that's a BS
argument and it sounded clever he
probably thought in his mind this one
makes a lot of sense and then all it
does is incriminate him oh so you're
saying you knew the guy who was
manipulating it wasn't supposed to hand
it to you and you fired it anyway you
knew that if someone manipulates the gun
other than the prop guy it must be
handed back to the prop guy and you
still took it aimed it at her pulled the
hammer back and fired it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time